do you agree that for democrats to make  a solid case for 2022  which really is going to kick off i mean  it might be january  it really might even be november  december some consultants are saying  do you think that joe biden needs one  more major accomplishment  in addition to vaccine rollout and covet  stimulus this calendar year  i do and i think he'll get one but the  question is what kind will it be if it  is just a bipartisan infrastructure bill  that may help and it may help in  moderate swing districts but i don't  think it's going to mobilize our base  and we need both we need  something for the independent swing web  voters but we also need to show our base  that we really delivered on progressive  change so i would say he needs one  big thing that uh appeals to the base as  well  yeah a uh a relatively small  infrastructure bill  that mitt romney loves i don't know if  that's necessarily gonna count as the  progressive change people are people are  waiting for